>> TO E UNIO TAPPER.
TO DEMOCRATIC CONTROL THISALPOST
RENOY GAORPR NEW
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE DANMARYLAND
ELECTION DENIER BACKED BRMERT
HESCUSS IS
MARYLAND Y HOGAN.T' COXD THE Q
MIT  THERE'S HE L RALLY,VEAT  PA
CHANCEE'LL
ASSOCIATIOE ATIC GOVER
ITLLIOTRTHIS
D  S WHO PROPPED THIS G A ELE
HE'S NOT A CANDIDATE.
>>D THE A PUT IN
MONEY TO FAN 142,000 WENT
WHO DID THIS. 'S REAY  VOTER PU
SHOWED UP AT THE POLLS.
IT'S ABOUT OUR STATE THAT FO
IN THE GENERAL ELECTION, T GOINE
>> T
THUYT QUD TO BE LDU'RETIATTLE F
GIVEN THIS ELECTION  PLUS THE GU
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHOALSO
UNHINGED, THERE'E
NGMAN LIZ CHENEY W
LOSE HER P IAU
IS IT TRYOLI
ANU'ING ITESTION WE LOD ARE NG
OVER.IGHT  L
WEHE
BEFORE THE NEXT ELECTIONI N NOV
BR THE
HEART AND SOUL OF TH
PARTY.
BEGINNING. NOVG
TO HAVE A DIFFERENWHT OF THESEED
LOSE AND THEN WEG TO
TION LATER,
WHAT KIND OF ATY AREE ING TOWE A
>> ONE OF THE THINGS W
AS THE DEGREE TOHIING
TOP TRUMP OFFICINN
AND SEVEN MINUTEAKE LUINRYEMENT
THE VIOLCES SUPP CKING THE PII
CALL BESIDEN TITED STATES TO TH?
>>I'NO.
GENERAL OF THE UNITEAYCALL BY T
UNITED STATES TO S THAT DAY?
>> I'M NOTTHAT, NO.
URVIEWERS, AT THUMP WA ACTION, U
WERE FIELDIN
MPSITTERGRESSIONAL LEADERS, O M
SO ACCOUNTS GLEEFU'S YOUR RE?
DN'T COME AS A
SURP T TO WATCH THESE
HEARINGSU'RE RIGHT.S TAKE ACTIO
THREE UR
NS THEHO  LEADERS ONG
POIMMEDIATELY.TOD.I SENT ICOUPL
NATIONAL GUA AND WATTEMPTING FO
GET APPROVAL OF THWHICH GET.
I L HOURTER T RYAN MTHHE ARM S
HEGUARD.
WHILNG NOTHING B
EL E NGNDANND SENDING IN
WE WERE TRYING ANE MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS.
UR --
TH WHAT YOU WERE DOIAT'S YOUR RT
>> IT DOESN'T E
IN
STONEWALLED.
BUT IT IS PRETTYI THINK
FOA LOT OF PEOPLE TH
PAYINGTTENTION.
HISTORYUF AS YOU KNOW YOUR DAD
CONGRESSE  AS A ICAN CORE  SG AS
WHAT W M
OF THE FACT THAT ETE
NG
INVESTIGATION, PLUL  THIS,
HONELYD F
ALOFS. AT HAPPENING.
WHAT DO K YOUR DAD WOULD OF TH
I LEARNED A Y
I'VE BEEN OF THE ONES
IT K LITTLE TOOPTOOVER AND OVER
DONALD TRUMP'SENCE,
DIMINISHNDINUEDIMINISH BETWE N Y
ACTIONS AS G MN THE WAY OF E ANY
OME N ABORTION.
MISTAKE?LOW ICAN GOVERNORSAKE AA
WE LITERALLY ARES
ABOUT WOMEN WHO HAMISCARESEING
FORCEDNTSINS
AV, GIRLE OLED TO CARR
R REON IOPLEA DO NOT HAVN ON IFE
STILL WAN
SOME -THEY STILL WOULD REASONABR
B NS-
>> PHOFE
AMERICA ISTHE GRAYEYREASONABLE
STRICTIONS, BUT T F
INK THEXBOSIDEIS
IS NOT GOING
IT'G TO
ON THE LEFT AUT MOST PEOPLE AR
AND THE TROUBLES THEY'RE
BUYING GROCEND GASNDWORRIEAB
>> LAST TIME WE SPOKE SAID SIDEA
PRESIDENTI RN N MARYLAND U  TO
IE CO